[Music]
hey you guys happy sunday here we are
back once again yep after how's how's
your guys weekend been yeah you think
he's been getting it sure why not okay
hi guys we can't ben
yeah that actually ought to be we ought
to have like jingle at the beginning and
you can sing it every time
okay and then tonight we're gonna watch
a haunting episode we're going to choose
one of them because a haunting show
tomorrow that's right it's going to be
good
uh we're going to do this uh
review
of what scent what my boy xanada sent me
sent this from the deep heart of the
desert
this is uh no country for old men which
is a neo western taking place in the
american southwest it's awesome
this is this is an amazing movie now
this was actually like the first time
that you had seen it right i had seen it
yeah i saw it in the theater uh came out
in 2007 and i saw it two or three times
subsequently because you know it's i i
love the coen brothers uh and i love all
their stuff so i would always go see
their stuff items we were talking about
xanad actually sent me a message and
said that um
we were talking about fargo which was uh
the movie that came out i think before
this one like the other cohen brothers
movie and i [ __ ] love fargo and i've
been like wanting to rewatch it but i
think you probably like this one better
than fargo yeah although although fargo
fargo's great too i thought i saw this
one but no i did i did i saw i think i
saw bits and pieces of it i think i saw
a couple of uh
scenes
but i've never i never saw the movie
yeah
i was like no i've never seen this yeah
and this movie i remember like there was
a huge buzz about this when it came out
because
um it won well it won a [ __ ] ton of uh
academy awards and it won best picture
uh javier bardem won uh the best
supporting actor and it got like a
couple other rewards too like it got
pretty much all the awards and turned up
in like pretty much every critics like
top 10 list for that year and it's
pretty easy to see why this is actually
uh if you didn't know it's based on a
novel by cormac mccarthy
and
this is actually from what i could
determine i haven't read
that quote i've read a couple of his
other books like i read the road and
stuff but um which is one of the most
depressing books ever but uh
from everything that i could determine
this movie adaptation
is very very close to the book there's a
couple things that are different
but
not much and some of the things that
they changed that the coen brothers
changed i think they probably changed
them for
like a decent reason you know what i
mean just in the service of like making
it work better as a movie maybe it it's
it's a western but it's not in kind it's
in the 1980s it's in 1980s i'd call it a
neo western it has a lot of
western tropes it's a western type
situation
basically outlaws
uh people surviving out in the desert
desert tactics but it but they got you
know modern guns and
cars and trucks and
uh there's no internet of course it's
it's 1980 no cell phones
they actually have a damn
tracker trying to track some money that
the guy stole from a drug cartel
he didn't really steal it he just it was
just there he just took it you know yeah
can you really steal it yeah everybody
was dead i mean it does belong to
somebody
uh
it's pretty good and it's got law men in
it
texas law men
and uh
[ __ ] psychopathic
tracker slash hitman that the cartels
used to
try to get that money back from a dude
who's basically a cowboy but he's got a
truck
you know it's good good movie yeah and
i'm watching this guy and i'm going man
this dude looks familiar
and i'm trying to place him
and it's the son
of the guy from andy vahreh
well yeah it's josh brolin josh like i
said he's been in a [ __ ] ton of bro
what's his dad's name
james bro james brolin that's right but
it looks just like james but i didn't i
knew that josh brolin had been in like a
[ __ ] ton of other movies but
i knew that probably you hadn't seen
most of those yeah so i said
probably you will know him because his
dad was james brolin who was the
amityville horror because i know you've
seen that yeah
so that's it
it's great though it's got great writing
uh there's a certain amount of realism
in it at times but then there's some
other times there's a little bit of i
wouldn't say fantasy but yeah there's
there's some there's some [ __ ]
hollywood movement moments in it but it
kind of adds to it
almost kind of like uh not as bad as
tarantino but kind of tarantino asked at
certain places
but um
yeah
and it it it's got kind of got kind of
an ambiguous ending uh so the ending's
kind of realistic kind of how it would
probably really go in in real life you
know i think that's kind of one of the
things that a lot of people like i don't
know if they necessarily complained
about it but i think a lot of people
that were kind of like um
were maybe confused by when they saw the
movie particularly and this is obviously
going to have spoilers you know because
we can't really talk about it otherwise
but particularly the scene where uh josh
brolin's character llewellyn moss is
killed and he's killed off screen
um and he's not killed by anton shiger
he's killed by uh like the other like
random the random mexican the cartels
yeah the the card and you don't see it
happen
but the thing about i think the first
time i saw this because like i said i
did see this in the theater and i think
at first i was just kind of like oh
that's how they want to do that but then
like the more i thought about it the
more i liked that they did that i think
well
joel and ethan cohen they like i mean
they've made like so many [ __ ] great
movies man it's just kind of like like i
said fargo they made raising arizona
which is one of my favorite movies of
all time
and they really like and blood simple
which actually um we should probably do
like one of these days because i think
that's on hbo max and that's another
really good one that i haven't seen in a
long time
but
i kind of feel like they really like to
play with
genre and even though you said that this
is a neo western which it is
but
they're kind of like playing with the
tropes of the western genre like
subverting the genre a little bit now
and not all of that comes from them
because a lot of that's from the novel
but
you know it it's kind of like playing a
little bit particularly with the
character that tommy lee jones plays ed
tom he's almost the narrator he's well
in the book he is
he's a much larger character in the book
um but his kind of whole thing about uh
you know a crime today it's different
than it was like back then like some of
the stuff that he talks about like some
of the crimes that he's like oh you know
we never saw anything like that so it's
almost kind of like he's hearkening back
to like the old days of the westerns
when it was like white hat black hat and
now everything's like morally ambiguous
but then wave of it coming and it's
society-wide and it's unstoppable but
the thing about it though is that that
him like having that attitude the movie
doesn't he's not necessarily right
because he has a discussion later on
with his
cousin i think that's his cousin like
the old guy in the wheelchair like where
he goes out there and the guy like
points out to him he's like you know our
grandfather great grandfather or
whatever he got shot in the back like by
a bunch of uh comanches or something
like that and it was just like as random
and stupid as like [ __ ] that's going on
nowadays he's like so what you're
feeling now there's it's like nothing
has changed um but when you get older
you always kind of like uh idealize the
past a little bit and i don't think
that's like the main point of the film
but i thought that was kind of like a
little thing that was going on yeah but
the the
that's that's the author's opinion there
there is
it is different uh but the main thing is
just the scale of what's happening now
the old west was not very violent
because
it was sparsely populated
when violence happened people remembered
it like okay corral
if that hap that happens all the time in
chicago it's totally forgotten every day
every every weekend an okay corral goes
down to chicago you didn't even hear
about it but that went down as legend in
the old west um well like you said
because the the population is so sparse
small real you know and uh it wasn't as
violent as uh as people think it was
yeah violence happened and they
remembered it that's why you're getting
these stories
so
there is some truth into what he was
saying he was saying it's endemic and
it's coming like a wave it was because
the population's gone up
um and
and in order to get noticed it has to be
even more violent than it was
um but you know it's still it's it's
storytelling you know this this this
movie is storytelling and one of the
things the reason why
some of the main characters because the
wife too you assume she dies off screen
she does well she she dies in the book
for sure like it says and then he shot
her like in the book yeah well here's
the thing that's how it would go down in
real life because because
you're used to western movies where the
main characters are kind of important
but in reality these chara
in reality these characters these people
would have been irrelevant i mean they
came out of trailer parks there's really
nothing special to them they were
well that's what i'm saying that's why i
liked yeah and i can see why some people
that were used to seeing like hollywood
westerns or hollywood movies that are
structured a particular way
would be mad that there wasn't like a
big showdown yeah
like you know xanada just said uh
there's no final showdown like even and
honestly in the
movie not so much in the book but in the
movie um the three main characters don't
ever meet each other they're like not
even at the same place at the same time
they're just kind of like constantly
following each other really um you know
obviously like anton like chases uh
llewellyn and shoots at him and stuff
like that but they don't like talk to
one another really except on the phone
so they're always kind of like at one
removed from each other always like
missing each other
and stuff like that and like you said i
really liked the how they kind of even
though i think when i first saw the
movie it kind of pissed me off like how
llewellyn got killed off screen even
though that does kind of happen in the
book too
but it's explained a little bit more but
not really but like you said i think
that's what i liked about it is because
these people
are not like important and like the
whole kind of theme of the movie is just
about
circumstances and fate and like kind of
the difference between
how much your self-determination
uh you know affects like how things turn
out and how much of it is just like luck
you know what i'm saying and i so i kind
of liked that aspect that's brought up
by the damn texas ranger guy woody
harrelson character he says he's talking
to the guy's wife and he's like look
he's in this way over his head he's oh
no he he was in the army you know he he
can handle it and [ __ ] the guy's like
no
and then uh and even the uh the
psychopathic hitman was like we know how
this is going to go
okay we know how this is going to end
it's wait it's going to end the way it
always adds you know me killing you
and
the only guy only guy from that
particular tree of characters to survive
was the hitman well the cops survived
but he retired yeah he retired yeah but
uh you know but i'm talking about
that trio
yeah the dude his wife and the hit man
the hitman survived he did and he called
it he said this is how it's going to go
down i'm going to kill your wife and
you're going to die
well that's the thing he offered
he offered he said well i'm going to
kill you regardless yeah which actually
didn't end up happening because the
mexicans killed him but i'm just saying
he's like well i'm gonna kill your guy
but if you give me the money oh that's
your wife then i'll let your wife go
yeah but because he said no that's not
how it's gonna happen like he tried to
like drop his nuts and say there was
gonna be a big showdown yeah but there
never was one
because he got killed so he was
he was kind of like honor bound or
obligated as much as a psychopath can
have uh you know a code of honor well
he's like well i said that i was going
to kill you so i'm here to do it like
you know no nothing personal yeah and he
told her the truth he said he could have
let you go he could have saved you but
he he chose not to yeah and which he
just chose to come after me because he
thought that yeah he thought that he um
had more uh control over his life than
he actually had right so
so uh psych uh hitman called it you know
and was telling the truth
[ __ ] the brody guy should have made
that deal
because he could have still gone after
him and killed him yeah but he should
have made it but he wasn't as smart as
he thought he was he wasn't as good as
he thought he was yeah all right and he
was
yeah so what he was uh from it's from
some infantry unit he'd been living out
in the country after that not really
doing a whole hell of a lot he was
outnumbered by a bunch of pro killers
professional killers
you know his chances are [ __ ] slim
because
quantity has a quality all its own
[ __ ] just going after three guys who
are [ __ ] trained fighters is [ __ ]
two
nah
in the in the military they'll tell you
do not attack an enemy until you have
[ __ ] three to one superiority in
other words you better have two guys
with you if you're gonna go after a dude
that's that's a winning ratio
you don't want three versus one the hard
way
your chances of survival [ __ ] very
very slim
well yeah i mean that's kind of why i
think that his character even though he
was kind he was pretty much a good guy i
mean yeah it was probably dumb for him
to take that money yeah but i feel like
most people would probably do the same
thing he was dumb for going back
yeah like he should have just taken it
and just run and although he didn't he
won should look for a transponder like
so like somebody said earlier like if
you find that much money yeah i would
have [ __ ] gotten rid of the bag that
it was in gone through all that [ __ ] but
he he didn't do that i mean you don't
find [ __ ] like that every day another
thing he didn't do is that
he had that
guy that the dying cartel narco guy in
there asking for water and he said well
i don't have any water
and didn't even make any [ __ ] agua he
didn't make any [ __ ] he didn't make
any [ __ ] moves to resolve that
situation he should have either shot
that dude then or [ __ ] taking him
with him that would have been a totally
different but see the fact that he
didn't do that like i said that's meant
to show that he's like at heart even
though yeah he just stole a bunch of
money which is probably dumb very good
but he but well no he was a good guy he
couldn't just kill the guy in cold blood
but he didn't take him and then later on
yeah he could have taken him but like i
said i would have taken him yeah okay
i've taken him in the money
and maybe worked something out with him
they probably would have paid you for
rescuing them one of them guys and
saving the money that was another thing
he could have done
yeah but i got your man i got him fixed
up i got your money
break me off some
they probably would give you some
maybe or they would just kill you anyway
i'd probably give you something
he'll probably give you some if you were
in a neutral area and you called him in
well like i said that was kind of the
whole point of his character was that he
was like a good guy like a relatable guy
but he did dumb [ __ ] that most people
would probably do like if put in the
same situation
um but then he made the mistake
of thinking that as i said he had more
control over the situation than he did
because he was a little bit at a
disadvantage not only because he was
outnumbered but because
you know again just like his wife said
or like the cop said that he was in over
his head and uh anton sugur the the guy
like following him was a complete and
utter
psychopath who absolutely did not care
about killing people at all and it was
just like all the same to him and that's
all that he wanted like was to get the
money back
and so he didn't really have any
limitations imposed by morality i guess
so
in that way he had an advantage over but
i was gonna say one of actually one of
my favorite scenes and like i said i
think some people maybe
um at the end of the movie like when
he's talking to when uh anton is talking
to carla jean um you know his the guy's
wife
and they don't actually show him kill
her
and some people were like well wait did
he kill her or not he totally did kill
her i mean like like i said in the book
it makes it very clear that he killed
her but in the movie he comes out the
house and then looks at the bottom of
his boots and if you remember there was
a bunch of scenes earlier where he very
specifically didn't want to get blood
like on his shoes or like on his socks
so they had brought that up before so
again that's kind of like
you should have extrapolated from that
and also because he had promised that he
would kill her if he didn't get the if
uh you know if llewellyn didn't give him
the money back and loelan didn't give
him the money back so he just promised
to kill her now the thing that's
interesting though is that this last
scene which is slightly different than
it was in the book
but when he talks to carla jean and she
makes the very reasonable like he you
know he does the whole coin flip thing
and says call it
um
and she refuses to because she basically
says you know that coin doesn't have
anything to say about it it's just you
making that decision so she was almost
like telling him that he was trying to
like absolve
himself of responsibility for killing
people like by putting it in the hands
of fate essentially
so the fact that after she tells him
that and then he kills her anyway and
then he gets in that car accident is
like really really interesting it's
almost kind of like because he made so
many statements going throughout the
film about you know this road led you to
this spot and things like that but then
when he sort of like refused to take
responsibility for his own actions um in
the sense that he's leaving things in
the hand of the coin
yeah you know what i mean uh then he
kind of
he realizes that he is also
subject to the whims of fate when he
just gets randomly hit by this car that
ran a red light you know what i mean
okay xander's asked me what i thought of
the guns what what my makeup okay
uh overall the for um
the guns that were shown were accurate
to 1980 all right um
the character what's the name main
character's name the uh the uh
brolin's character i don't remember what
it's like luella yeah llewellyn knows
his guns when he shows up at the damn
uh kill zone where all the damn dead
narcos were
he takes the best guns that he saw there
were some uh
i think there were i think there were
some ak-47s there on the ground i saw a
couple of mack tans
and uh he goes right for the best one
that was there which was an mp5k those
hadn't been out for very long they came
out in about 76 i think
77.
so that was that was a very exotic very
expensive
um for that place and time
the mp5k is a you know
it's a pdw a personal defense weapon uh
you didn't see that in movies first time
i saw that in the movies uh was uh
lethal weapon one
the south african
bodyguards to the uh ambassador had one
and [ __ ] mel gibson what is that
underneath there is that something south
african it was german but
so he takes that
and mysteriously loses it you know uh he
had it for a while then he doesn't have
it anymore which i was like did he lose
it in that car like after he hijacked
that car and then like he got shot at
and then like he left a bunch he had it
for a while and then you don't see it
anymore i don't know what happened to it
but that would have been a priority to
keep something like that in 1980 so i
don't know why he abandoned that
um
and then he off that one dead narcotic
he found he took a um it was a chrome
pimped out chrome 1911 45 auto i think
it might have been engraved too which
those were as accurate to mexico um
mexicans loved 1911's they still love
them to this day there's they're still
down there
um but before gun control hit mexi
mexico
back in the days when they could buy
guns that was one of their most popular
one and they would cowboy those things
[ __ ] up when you think of cowboy
you're thinking of [ __ ] white dudes
no man the mexicans got the cowboy thing
down man they they'd take those 1911s
and they'd put scroll work on them and
mexican eagles and uh mayan and aztec
[ __ ] calendars and just whatever you
know what i mean they were they would
pimp them things out like crazy
so he took that that was a nice piece um
assassin was using a uh look like uh
um
what was that thing winchester 1100
or no remington 1100 i think it's either
look at 1100 um semi-automatic shotgun
is what it looked like i can go back and
check and have it had been suppressed
which i don't know how feasible that is
um that might have been a movie gun only
they made it for the for the movie
specifically never heard of anything
like that i saw a video earlier where
they said that that had been made yeah
usually
usually with things like semi-auto
shotguns from the older ones in that era
you couldn't suppress something like
that uh it would probably
[ __ ] up the gas operations some some of
the stuff was kind of semi-recoil
operated where the barrel itself would
kind of move in about a quarter of an
inch to help unlock the action it all
depended on what kind of shotgun that
was um because i i don't know the exact
model do you remember what they said
what what model it was no
now if it was pump action i might buy
into that a little bit
more okay um
but man i don't know how how well of a
gas seal you'd be able to get on a damn
shot shell with a buffer plastic [ __ ]
buffer behind it going through those
baffles like that
probably couldn't get a very good seal
but it would probably moderate it would
probably act more like a moderator than
a suppressor uh which moderators don't
legally meet the definition of a
suppressor they don't reduce enough
decibels
uh they just kind of make something
sound a little bit more mild
but it's still loud you know
um but the idea of a
shotgun as quiet as what they were
showing no i ain't buying that at all
[ __ ] no
a fully suppressed nine millimeter
pistols is still louder than a 22
unsuppressed
you're not hiding the fat fact that
shots are fired
you're just not quite sure what it was
that you're being shot at with
and you don't have to wear a hearing
protection and using them indoors is a
lot easier
it's not ringing your bell but if you
get real battle hardened like me i'd
shoot my [ __ ] belt fed m60 indoors
you know inside [ __ ] confined areas
like [ __ ]
uh sandbag bunker complexes on live fire
exercises and [ __ ] but i'm also deaf
[Laughter]
just ask jenny i'm also pretty deaf
well i shut up my [ __ ] pretty deaf
and i think you might be deafer than i
yeah which is saying something yeah i'm
pretty [ __ ] dead
there were times where [ __ ] me and
[ __ ] sparks laid down [ __ ]
laid down [ __ ] fields of grazing fire
[ __ ] probably [ __ ] 2 000 rounds of
belted ammunition and not a [ __ ]
inside a [ __ ] sandbag bunker
just during [ __ ] live fire exercises
and no no hearing and protection i don't
even remember ringing in my ears
afterwards it just became normal
but you know that's because we shot our
ears out back in those days
we were young and dumb
danny rowling is requesting us to do
legend trippers a haunting
uh
yeah we'll do it we'll do it but i want
to move that one down a little bit
further in the ranks the legend trippers
was kind of one of the oddball ones we
still have some of the [ __ ] high
profile ones that we want i want to do
first
well somebody asked us to do uh darkness
follows or echoes of the past yeah yeah
i'd rather do something like because i
think those were like actually requested
yeah
yeah
um
yeah danny rowling also was talking
about the cattle air gun yeah i was
really like freaked out by that the
first time i saw the movie because it's
just so but when you think about it it's
really like the perfect weapon for him
to have because like i said he's just
like a stone cold psychopath and he just
considers people like cattle like not
like people so he's just like [ __ ]
yeah it's more of a psychological thing
you gotta carry around this big old air
bottle there's something else that's uh
a lot better than that that's a lot more
a lot quieter and a lot more deadly and
a lot smaller
and that's a shark bang stick
you can get them in 38 special
and
they're quiet but you got to make
content you when you cut it down
cut it down small put it down bicycle
grip on it
put a 38 special cartridge in it and
[ __ ] hit somebody like that you won't
hear anything
i don't really think that anton sugar
was worried about anybody hearing
anything he really didn't seem to give
much of a crap about
getting caught or
any well he did get caught at the
beginning of the movie and then he just
very very uh
methodically stepped out of the
they like stepped over and just like
very coldly like strangled that cop to
death that defeated death so he wasn't
obviously very worried about in the book
i think they made it made it kind of
more clear that he sort of allowed
himself to get caught just to see if he
could get out of it yeah um they didn't
really say that in the movie but it
didn't really matter because like i said
he really seemed like
i mean he really like somebody said
earlier like yeah he really did earn
that oscar i mean he was like the most
inhuman
character and i've seen him in tons of
other stuff and he's a great [ __ ]
actor but i mean he was just like
[ __ ] scary in that you he really did
not seem like anybody that had any
emotions at all or was even
they said that when they were looking
for somebody to be in the you know to do
that role they said we wanted somebody
that was like almost like they were from
mars you know what i mean like they were
just this kind of weird and i think he
totally totally pulled that off and did
i say mention earlier that i saw i was
watching a video earlier that said i
guess a few years ago like they'd had
like all these psychiatrists and
psychologists like all get together and
like watch all of these movies that had
like you know crazy people are like
serial killers and they said which movie
adaptation like which movie character is
the closest to like what an actual
psychopath is and it was this guy like
that's who they voted for because they
said he just seems like he has no
humanity at all
and i think he really really pulled that
off but like but like i said he did i
think the reason that his character was
so interesting too is that he did have a
code of honor he didn't kill everybody
that he could have killed
he just kind of killed people that got
in his way or sometimes if he was just
for shits and giggles he would you know
do the coin flip thing just to [ __ ] with
them
but
you know he didn't kill the he didn't
kill the guy at the um the gas station
like he let him do he wanted he won the
coin toss so he's like it wouldn't have
been fair if he'd killed him then but he
killed other people just like because
like i said because he needed their car
or just for no reason at all
but
he didn't um he when he went to that
the place where he um you know was uh
shot the guy that was i guess his boss
or like work for the company or whatever
like he shot that guy but he didn't
shoot the other guy that was in the
office like the accountant guy like he
didn't shoot that guy because that guy i
guess didn't have anything to do with
like whatever pissed him off so but you
know there's that so i don't know i
don't know do you see me he's like no i
see you yeah we'll see that's if you
were smart that's what you said i
absolutely did not see you at all no sir
i don't don't put that [ __ ] cattle
gun in my [ __ ] head
yeah but one thing too like i always i
don't know why i've seen this movie like
a bunch of times but i always forget how
funny it is and it's not like funny like
raising arizona is funny but it's that
very very and i guess like a lot of coen
brothers movies have this like fargo is
like this too where it just has this
very very dry like black humor
and particularly in tommy lee jones's
character like some of the [ __ ] he says
in this just like made me laugh my
[ __ ] ass deputy's dumb as [ __ ] i know
and it's like i really really like that
that guy that pla that played the deputy
um that played his deputy he actually
wanted to be uh he wanted the josh
brolin role okay they said he tried out
for it like a whole bunch of times yeah
but they didn't give it to him so they
were like what's his name garrett
dillahunt that's the actor's name but i
mean
tommy lee jones is just so great in this
like just the funny discussions they
have about when the when him and the
deputy are talking about like all the
mexicans that got killed out in the
desert and he's like you know they were
mexicans or wait are they still mexicans
like now that they're dead and he's just
like yeah that's the thing isn't it like
when when did they stop being mexican
yeah like like just a funny [ __ ] like
that and just the way he says that he's
just like so
like sardonic and it's just i [ __ ]
love the the sense of humor in this one
even though most of the stuff that
happens is like really grim this is
actually a pretty grim movie but i
really like those little and i actually
i don't know if that's in the book or
not because like i said i haven't read
this book but i've read the road which
is absolutely not funny i don't think
there's any humor in that at all so i
don't really know if there's any humor
in the book or if that was just a cohen
brothers thing because i know that's
very much a coen brothers thing that
sense of humor they had because you know
they made the big lebowski too right
yeah yeah yeah same guys but
you know um
i'm just yeah i had a feeling that
you were really gonna like this movie so
i'm glad you did now you said last night
you said you weren't sure if you liked
the ending or not i thought about it for
a while i was like yeah okay because i
did kind of miss the uh having a big
showdown at the end of it yeah
but i understand why they did thinking
about it i'm kind of glad they did it
because like i said that wasn't really
this would have been another one yeah
that wasn't really the point of the
story there's a lot of those and it was
this would it would have been another
movie with that
so
it tried to make an impression on you in
a different way about how by the way
this wasn't this was a movie but it
wasn't really a movie this is how it
would have really went down these people
really weren't that important
yeah that's what i mean it's like you
know the only reason that llewellyn got
involved at all totally look it was just
totally luck he just happened to be out
hunting and he happened to see you know
what happened and he's like oh there's
the money so he just got like sucked
into this like much larger world and so
i kind of think too that the the movie
is showing that you know reality all of
this stuff like goes on without you
you're just kind of like this piddly
little yeah and the idea of one man
going up against the mexican mob and
winning nah ain't going to happen
yeah so i can kill dudes all the time
that think that all the time all those
dudes that end up in them damn videos
where they cut them apart with a knife
they thought they could [ __ ] beat the
mexican mob no you can't they outnumber
you and they have [ __ ] a [ __ ] ton of
money and a lot of experience and a lot
of cops and ex-soldiers in their ranks
that teach them and train them up
just like a professional army
the best especially you know a good
narco armies like that
one man has no chance against them
yeah and i like that this like i said
this movie is very
yeah yeah it has like themes about
certain things so it's kind of
thematically constructed in that way but
it is absolutely a lot more realistic
this is probably absolutely what would
happen yep uh you know if you
were in this scenario like i said the
guy wasn't yeah he'd been in vietnam and
yeah he was a welder so he and he'd been
like lived out in the desert so he was
kind of tough and everything but like i
said he was outnumbered he wasn't a
psychopath and he didn't really he
didn't really have i guess the luxury of
being on the wrong side of the law yeah
you know he seemed like he was mostly a
good law abiding citizen yeah so
he didn't really know
those narcos had [ __ ] guys working
inside damn mexican
mexican law enforcement that has they
have access to their computer files they
can do [ __ ] all kinds of background
checks on you using law enforcement
[ __ ]
computers
and then you can hand all that [ __ ] over
to the [ __ ]
to the mob
all right that's how they do that [ __ ]
okay
they got cops in their ranks and people
that work in the [ __ ] their police
departments they do background check on
you and [ __ ] find out everything
about you and all your relatives
and they hand all that information over
the mob and you're [ __ ] dead
they'll get you
well the thing about this too it's like
even though llewellyn was
smart um you know and he did think of
some things like oh [ __ ] he's gonna uh
he'll be able to like pull the record to
my car and figure out where i live and
stuff so he knew like to get the [ __ ]
out of the house
but there were some things that he
forgot about like yeah he knew to get
the [ __ ] out of the house but he left a
phone bill there yeah so all so all that
anton had to do was like look at the
phone bill and just like call people
he had a clean break he got in got into
the [ __ ] kill zone where the shootout
went down got the money all right and
got to his car and went back home
cleanly they didn't know who that was he
had that tracker in there but he could
have found that tracker he had time the
range on that thing wasn't unlimited
yeah he could have thrown that tracker
away and got rid of that thing and
spread that money out and then moved
away like a man
okay the thing is though is that you'd
have to move away
and hide your wife to make sure that
they didn't know who you were that would
take a long time you'd have to wait for
a couple of years before you were sure
that they didn't know who you were
then you could go back and collect your
wife and start buying stuff
that's what i'm saying i'm just kind of
like didn't any any time just this is a
pro tip any time like in a movie or
anything so any time in real life you
find like the big [ __ ] stash i'm like
did you guys not see a simple plan uh
and then like how that worked out
because that was the same thing where
they found like a crash plane it was a
drug deal and it was actually wasn't a
drug deal it was uh it was ransom money
and it was like three guys found it and
like it
everything just completely went to [ __ ]
um as smart as you might think you are
uh you're there's gonna be something
that you don't think of and i kind of
feel like
yeah probably 99 of the people would be
tempted to take it um
but
i kind of feel like in the end it's
probably not worth it you know what i'm
saying yeah so
they're saying that the the hitman was
pissed off with the [ __ ] haircut as
barbara gave him no 1988 in 1980 you saw
those haircuts they were from the 70s
well the guys with them they said that
the reason they said they wanted him
like i said they wanted him to look
it look like kind of alien or like out
of time and place like with the clothes
that he wore and stuff like that um they
said they actually got the idea for that
haircut from a photo of a guy from 1979
that was standing in front of like a
strip club or something like that like
it was an old like uh 1979 but it's like
new york city or something that was the
70s cool guy haircut from like 73
that was out of style by that time
all right but he should have had a big
[ __ ] collars leisure suit and [ __ ]
and he was too old to have that haircut
at that point that that's the same
haircut the bee gees had at certain
times okay
yeah i mean i remember seeing people
with those haircuts but
i think that that haircut i mean that
haircut probably look looks bad on
everybody but it probably doesn't look
that weird on other people but they
wanted it look to look really really
weird on him well it did which it did
because they wanted him to look like
really [ __ ] strange and honestly that
one scene where he stops at one car like
before he kills the guy with the cattle
gun and like that creepy creepy smile
that he makes like out this that it's
like he looks like so [ __ ] weird in
this he actually he gained a lot of
weight for this rolex that haircut was
supposed to be
on a [ __ ] younger dude in a leisure
suit in some old school nightclub that
they used to have yeah when a nightclub
was a bunch of tables in front of a
[ __ ] stage that's what those
[ __ ] wore
yeah a lot and they thought they were
real cool
you know
seven or eight years later it looked
[ __ ] crazy as [ __ ] though because
they had aged
yeah because [ __ ] had changed and they
they tried to have them haircuts
sometimes you saw photographs of it in
catalogs or just you know
you'd still see some of my [ __ ] with
that and he'd be balding and he still
had that haircut trying to maintain that
[ __ ] it just did a [ __ ] party
yeah danny rowling said a life where you
have to watch your back 24 7 is not a
good life to live yeah you wouldn't
really be able to enjoy it
i mean if i found two million dollars
sure [ __ ] yeah i'd be tempted to take it
but then i'd be thinking to myself well
i can't spend it
um
i'd have to like
maybe back then but not nowadays i don't
think those bills would have been marked
or anything you'd and you'd
you'd have to be in a totally cash
economy you wouldn't want to buy
anything real big you'd have to launder
it
yeah keep on the download before you
were sure they weren't watching and even
then you could never be it was a bunch
of absolutely it was a bunch of hundreds
so you'd have to go around every
over a period of time spending hundreds
and getting changed and then once you
had the change you could
you could spend that no problem
but um you'd have to [ __ ]
spread them hundreds out
yeah
that's the thing i think that most
people would be tempted to be like woo
i'm going to go buy a [ __ ] you know
buy a house with that that's what i mean
because that cash would show up inside
of a banking system somewhere and if
they had agents in there if the cartels
had agents in there looking for those
numbers they were saying well wait a
minute oh all these numbers came out of
the purchase of that house then they
know who bought that house yeah you
couldn't buy that house with those exact
bills
you'd have to [ __ ] change those bills
for other bills yeah so they were all
hundreds so you'd have to run around in
restaurants in a place where you don't
live
getting [ __ ] meals every day three
meals a day to go 300 a day
cash a day
you know and you'd be gaining a lot of
weight
buy a twenty dollar well you don't
necessarily have to buy food at
restaurants you could buy the easiest
way because yeah but i mean you can
change a hundred you could buy other
things like you could just go to like
the drugstore and buy like some [ __ ]
yeah i don't know some aspirin or some
[ __ ] yeah you're throwing the [ __ ] away
every time you buy it and then you're
collecting all this [ __ ] [ __ ] in a
big old [ __ ] bag
and then you slowly get rid of all those
hundreds
into change
and then you go back to a bank and you
take all those [ __ ] changes and get
it get it for five hundreds or one
thousands and buy a house with that you
could back in those days nowadays you
couldn't buy a house with cash i don't
think not the united states people might
be like they want to know where you got
where you got it yeah yeah because
nobody really has that much cash other
than you know drug dealers no i couldn't
walk in here 475 thousand dollar house
in cash
no they i think the banks are so get
alerted when you buy something yeah
supposed
well like i said rightfully so because
that's usually drug money drug money
because who the [ __ ] else has 475
thousand dollars just in cash laying
around nobody that's who usually what
they'll do is they'll do something like
buy a used car lot with the money
buy a used car a lot and they run that
used car lot for a few years
and then they start claiming that
they're
selling cars they are selling cars
but they're saying well all this money
came from the car lot or the [ __ ]
coin operated laundry yeah money
laundering yeah that's what that is yeah
john smith said real kick in the balls
is that money was probably just pocket
change to the cartel it probably was it
was what it was two million dollars two
million dollars
yeah but that's not realistic though um
chances are they they wouldn't have time
or money to spend on lost money they
would just go ah [ __ ] we got more money
coming and they just okay here's an
example uh cocaine cowboys on that
program
which is real it happened here in
florida and these are the miami guys who
were bringing in cocaine
um they would just
buy these safe houses all over
and they were houses where they could
take their girlfriends and bring in big
pallets of money and
drugs and stage things and some of them
had shortwave radio centers where they
could talk to the airfields down in
columbia and crap you know and um
they would kind of regularly buy and
sell these houses so they were also
doing kind of like real estate
deals you know
they didn't really care about the real
estate money that much once you make a
certain amount of money you can't help
but to make more and more and more money
becomes like fake money after a while
well they sold one of those houses to
somebody and a few years later
that person called the cops and up in
the attic was a pallet of a couple
million dollars in cash
a pallet of it sitting up in the attic
and it was money they forgot about they
just forgot i just forgot about can you
imagine just like being able to forget
about two million dollars yeah yeah that
we did stick that up there didn't you
yeah they asked them about it later oh
yeah we forgot all about that
because they had lots of those they just
[ __ ] pallets of [ __ ] money
everywhere and they would just
store it and stash it in places and hand
out money to people and
buy things and over time just forget
about where they had money stashed
it must be nice yeah
it's like play money
didn't matter and they get pulled over
by the cops down there in miami and
[ __ ]
can i see your driver's license
registration you know what you know all
this kind of stuff and you got and the
guy just goes look
i got i got a big old uh stash of
[ __ ] cocaine in there about a million
dollars
of it and i got a million dollars in
cash back there why don't you just take
it and the cop go back there and take it
and just leave
yeah
okay so don't think the [ __ ]
things actually work no
not really
muddy talks [ __ ] walks
dude did that on a date
he had a date with him he didn't want to
get pulled over and go to jail he would
have been right back out they locked his
ass up gave him [ __ ] i think 10 years
and [ __ ] a few weeks later [ __ ] or
was it no
about a year later they realized he
wasn't in prison anymore he got out they
just let him out
they were still counting him on the damn
roll
account like he was in prison but some
mysterious way he was just let out the
back door if you have enough money
anything can happen pretty much yep zana
also says i love fargo i do as well and
honestly i've been wanting to i told you
i wanted i've been wanting to rewatch
that because i saw that in the theater
too that came out in uh the year before
this one i think didn't it yeah i kind
of feel like but uh yeah i don't you
would probably like that as well that's
similar to this one i kind of feel like
it's a little bit funnier and it's set
in
not in the desert but it's more it's
like in uh it's minnesota like uh or
fargo no fargo duh north dakota uh so
it's kind of like set in the winter so
it's like all snowy and everything but
it's like similarly themed like it's a
crime kind of thing but like with some
black comedy but yeah
so maybe we'll do that one too like
eventually because i've been wanting to
rewatch that so uh do you have anything
else you would like to add no uh we're
good we're gonna ship out we're shipping
out shirts too and aren't we uh tomorrow
morning tomorrow they're gonna come and
get it it's all it's all packed up right
all right all right cam guy tomorrow
morning uh they pick up on the shirts
yeah they're gonna pick it up tomorrow
morning got it all packed up and all the
postage and everything like that yeah so
yeah all right so tomorrow
we're gonna do
uh our haunting monday that's right so
we don't know like i said i know so some
of you guys like want to see legend
trippers and somebody said to do um what
was the one called the counselor
uh but probably like i said we had a
bunch that were requested and i remember
darkness follows was requested i
remember echoes from the past was
requested uh where evil lurks i think
that was requested as well we didn't do
that one yet did we um so maybe we'll do
one of those i don't know we'll see
another thing i want to announce is that
i opened up a twitch account on twitch
where i'm going to stream um me playing
uh the classic [ __ ] tomb raider games
uh sophie wants wants to see much to see
me play those games i don't have a uh a
microphone yet so i won't be talking but
i'll be able to read uh what you call it
um chats uh so if you guys want to watch
me play video games on
on twitch uh it'll probably be another
couple days before i start doing it uh
my name on there is tom 13 o'clock all
lower case there's no apos possibly just
talk
tom 13 o'clock on twitch
you can friend me on there
you have to get a microphone one of
these days so people if they're cheap i
think they're about 30 bucks 40 bucks a
headset with a microphone on there yeah
i got one i can hear through the
microphone if they can hear through the
headsets
it's a usb one i can hear through the
headsets but i can't somehow it's not
picking up the microphone
it's one for uh skype
yeah it's old we just had i don't even
remember where we got it from i didn't
even he comes in and he's i was like i
don't remember buying that or i don't
remember so i'm sitting there trying to
turn the microphone on and i don't think
it can turn on i don't think it's right
but i can hear it through the headphones
oh well like i said i don't think
they're all i need to get that wireless
one anyway yeah because that was like i
said that we've had that for probably
years i didn't we've had it for so long
i didn't even remember we had it yeah
but i think i even take get super chats
on skype not skype on on twitch yeah
there you go see that'll be fun yeah you
can play all the uh lara croft play the
laura croft games and [ __ ] talk [ __ ]
about it
i'm gonna start off with legend and then
anniversary and then i'll probably do uh
underworld
yeah those are all those are all fun
yeah maybe you could do fall out too at
some point yeah that's so long yeah
that's true this year so well
all right so uh thanks everybody for
dropping by today talking about uh the
coen brothers talking about no country
for old men and we'll be back tomorrow
talking about a haunting episode as we
usually do on mondays so have a good
rest of your weekend you guys and we
will see you again tomorrow evening bye